orschala barents is sorting and packing
up her waste plastic from the past week
in time for a special pickup service
recycling household trash
is still the exception here in cape town
bosch labarans
only started separating her paper in
plastic recently
as part of a pilot project
i never realized you know how bad
things was until i started saving
plastic
i have never never thought about it
but i'm so glad to be doing my best
and every little bit counts currently
just seven and a half percent of south
africans
recycle their waste
the result is mountains of plastic and
other refuse across the country
until now the only form of household
waste recycling here
was done by informal waste collectors
chad robertson decided to take action
so right here we've got a lot of illegal
dumping uh
quite a big issue in the city of cape
town according to some stats
around we're spending around 400 million
rand a year on illegal dumping and
cleaning it up
whereas you know we could be spending
money on rather creating solutions to
solve this problem
right behind the landfill there's a no
dumping sign
yeah very ironic yeah it's it's
it's actually not very ironic because at
most dumping sites you will see a no
dumping sign
so it's quite a norm for us here in cape
town
chad robertson wants to encourage cape
towners to bring about
change his regimenized startup is
primarily aimed
at people from the poorest parts of the
city
south africa is a very unequal society
and that extends to waste disposal
[Music]
if you're in a low-income community for
example there's really not
nothing available for you besides the
informal collectors would collect the
recyclables because
the private companies wouldn't operate
there nor would the city's free service
operate as i mentioned that's only in
your upper income communities
regeneres which he founded to help
resolve cape town's waste problem
is located in the bridgetown suburb in
the east of the city
in 2018 the startup launched a pilot
project here
tailored to the needs of lower income
areas
[Music]
zikla and ziva mafume begin their shift
at the collection point
while one starts sifting through and
sorting the items from the past week
the other sets off on his cargo track
siva mavume does a tour of the
neighborhood once a week
the service is a new one for the
residents of bridgetown
siva mavume collects paper plastic and
cans from participants
meanwhile 500 households are taking part
today he'll stop by 150 homes
he makes a careful note of how much each
sack weighs
[Music]
his trikes cargo cage fills up quickly
residents involved in the pilot project
aren't charged for the pickup service to
the contrary
participants all receive a fixed sum in
rimali
for each waste pickup rimali is a
virtual
currency that can be saved up and then
spent on shopping
vouchers mobile phone data packages and
donations
thank you so much yay
i need to buy dog food so this can go
towards the dog food
because it's so expensive
makes his way back to the depot the
project provides jobs for people
who used to be informal trash collectors
and unemployed young people like siva
mavumi
colleagues bring the sorted reusable
materials to a recycling plant
where the waste is turned into a new
resource
regeneise's efforts have won it a
national social innovation award
though support from the local
authorities has been sluggish
especially when it comes to creating the
infrastructure
for more collection points but chad
robertson and his team are undeterred
we are still pushing our optimism comes
through small things you know seeing the
impact
that it makes seeing positive reviews
from customers
and being able to grow the business as
well the vision is to really
scale our service throughout cape town
and south africa the recycling model
and get people not only to recycle but
to start living more circular
ursula barrance is a convert she's happy
about the vouchers
but even happier that she's now doing
something about the waste
problem
[Music]
people will come to realize that we all
need to do something to make the change
be the change you want to see
be the change and i'm glad that i got
started late in life but i got started
rather late than never the regina's team
are hoping
that the government will also increase
its support so that recycling
can soon become available to all south
africans
you